Ask anybody around you this simple question:
“What is gravity?”
And what you’d probably hear is
“it’s something that pulls objects towards the earth”
or “it’s a force exerted by the earth
to pull objects towards it”.
Now before we get to the basics of gravitation,
there is one thing I want you to understand
well.
Rather there’s one thing I want you to forget!
Forget the fact that gravity has got to do
ONLY with the earth and the objects close
to it.
That’s NOT gravity!
We’d see examples where objects are falling
to the ground and we assume that it’s the
only concept we need to know about gravity.
Yes of course its gravity that pulls the objects
towards the earth but that’s NOT the only
thing you need to understand about gravity!
So what is gravity?
Consider your screen to be the Universe.
And these are any two objects in the universe.
They could be planets or humans
or animals or whatever.
Just that they both have non-zero mass!
In this case, both objects are pulling the
other object towards each other.
This object is pulling this one towards itself.
And the other object is pulling this one towards itself.
This attractive force between any two masses
in the universe is called the
It’s not ONLY the force that earth uses
to pull objects towards it!
But yes, as all of us have earth as our habitat,
most examples we see for gravitation will
relate to the earth pulling objects towards it.
But you should know that it’s not the only
force that explains gravitation.
In the case of earth and a human being, the
earth is one object and the human being is
another.
Both are pulling the other towards themselves.
But why does this happen?
If you do a lot of research in to what gravity
really means, you may find out that gravity is
not actually a force and it’s just an illusion
So for now, it’s enough to know that gravitational
force is just the attractive force between
any two objects with non-zero mass separated
by a distance.
After knowing the basics, you’d probably
have many questions in mind.
Does the apple fall towards the earth or does
the earth move towards the apple?
If two objects always attract each other,
why don’t two humans get pulled towards
each other?
Why don’t two stars collide with each other?
After watching our videos based on Gravitation
you will be able to answer all these questions
and understand various concepts related to them!
Happy Learning!